sunflower Bay so if you didn't know
already we're married and I just want to
know how many kids were having sunflower
I think it would take me meeting you in
order for us to be married and having
kids right I don't think we've met yet
hey guys I'm back at it this week
reading and responding to your YouTube
comments so this must be a very stupid
question how often does a person need to
change on this Miko I would do it daily
fungi love warm wet dark environments
when Yuri wear the same underwear that
fungus can start growing on your skin
and you will get a condition known as
jock itch or some women can get a yeast
infection Sumiko change up that
underwear daily please hey dr. Mike hey
Ruthie apparently pollen season started
already I think a spring allergy video /
pollen video would be awesome since that
is something I've been suffering for for
about six years it's a little bit of a
complex answer for those patients of
mine who have springtime allergies
there's definitely something to be said
about taking a daily controller
medication there are websites that you
can visit to see pollen counts like the
pollen forecast for that day there are
days when the pollen count is so high
that a person like you should not be
outdoors or should at least strictly
limit the time spent outdoors perhaps
getting a filter for your home that is
certified to remove pollen from the air
would be ideal would you wear a shirt
with a few buttons left undone when you
publish your next video I think you
would get more views well Sean I
appreciate the compliment yeah I would
do that I have no problem wearing a
shirt with a couple buttons on them I
don't know how low you want me to go
like those old-school Russian gangsters
when I grew up I'm Russian I used to
hang out in Brighton Beach and the guys
would have their shirts down to here and
I'll be back what is going on what's the
maximum frequency that one should eat
fish in a week it's a great question
Omar are you eating wild fish versus
farmed fish are you eating smaller fish
like tuna or salmon or are you eating
large fish like swordfish larger fish
predator type of fish generally have
higher levels of mercury
I do think it's relatively safe to do
like three or four times a week eating a
tuna or sounded peachy Montoya what a
name I don't know if that's your name
where you use her name but it's awesome
I love peaches by the way that's why I'm
obsessed with peach Snapple Shh a lot of
sugar dr. Mike how long will it take for
large stretch marks to fade away stretch
marks once they're there they're there
and while there are some laser
procedures and some surgical procedures
that can get rid of them it's very
difficult near impossible to get rid of
stretch marks because it is scar tissue
it's basically damage that's happened to
your skin how do stretch marks happen
well your skin is naturally somewhat
elastic right if I pull on my skin here
just doesn't tear and rip and bleed
right but if your body size changes
rapidly you gain muscle too quickly you
are pregnant you put on a lot of weight
because you've been eating poorly any
one of those drastic changes where the
skin has to adapt rather quickly you're
gonna get some damage there and when you
have damage you get scar tissue
hey dr. Mike is a true alkaline water
better than regular one Diana I have
never seen this to be true I understand
why some people are promoting it and I
think it's based on flawed science or at
least incomplete science what you put in
your body whether it's alkaline or
acidic it doesn't change the acidity of
your blood that's not how it works I was
wondering if you would have become
something other than a doctor what would
have been Maggie I would have been a
detective I loved investigating putting
pieces together and seeing little things
that other people don't see little
details like Sherlock Holmes style and I
think being a doctor is very similar to
being a detective so Lauren Garcia does
muscle really weigh more than fat well
that's like the typical trick question
that people ask what wastes more a pound
of feathers or a pound of gold they
weigh the same muscle doesn't weigh more
than fat and fat doesn't weigh more than
muscle now that being said muscle is
more dense so it would look like less
muscle is needed to weigh the same as
more fat because fat is less dense but
in reality one pound of muscle equals
one pound of fat what do you think of
cranberry supplements do they really
prevent UTIs well Andrea I'll tell you
this cranberry supplements the way that
they're supposed to work is they're
supposed to acidify your urine when you
acidify your urine it
makes it less likely or supposedly makes
it less likely that you'll get an
infection because bacteria don't like to
live in an acidic environment that's the
premise behind taking cranberry
supplements number one I don't like
supplements so I would much rather you
just have cranberries or drink cranberry
juice natural stuff not to concentrate
the evidence honestly like I've looked
at it it's fairly weak but again because
we look at harms vers benefits in these
types of situations I think that the
benefits probably outweigh the harms if
there is even a slight chance that
cranberries can help your UTI or prevent
a UTI go ahead and eat some cranberries
because what's the harm in eating some
cranberries they're rich in antioxidants
and if they help prevent UTIs boom you
got yourself a two-in-one deal dr. Mike
I think you would look good with bleach
blonde hair this wasn't a request it's a
demand chill Beach blonde hair I think I
look really weird I don't know maybe if
you get this video to 200,000 likes I'll
dye my hair blonde oh my god I probably
shouldn't have started right I didn't
commit to that there was no handshake
don't get your lawyers involved hey dr.
Mike I have a question why is it that I
always get ear infections I clean my
ears every day use nasal spray and sleep
on a heating pad each night okay Emma
you make one of the biggest mistakes
that my patients most often make
cleaning your ears I assume with q-tips
q-tips what they actually do
number one instead of getting earwax out
they just end up pushing the earwax back
into the ear and clogging it therefore
making it more susceptible to infection
the second thing they do because the
q-tip the cotton is slightly rough and
the area within your ear is very gentle
very sensitive when you put the q-tip in
your ear and scratch your ear may feel
good but what you're doing is you're
creating micro tears little irritations
on the skin that basically make it more
susceptible for bacteria to get in there
and caused an infection so by cleaning
your ears every day with acute sip
you're actually making it more likely
that you're gonna get an infection what
are your thoughts on colon hydrotherapy
and coffee enema and would you recommend
these therapies Melinda no I would not
never in no way way sense or how of the
word would I ever recommend a coffee
enema or colon hydrotherapy this is the
deaf
nation of garbage please do not waste
your money on it as you can tell my vein
is popping out right now because I'm
quite angry at these people are taking
your money and misguiding you and giving
you lofty promises coffee enemas are BS
and anyone who tells you that they're
good for your health is a POS just calm
down sweater gunas i'm sorry if i said
that wrong it's i don't know what the
double dots represent I already have
black rings under my eyes how can I get
rid of them people always assume that
I'm sick so I know this is a great
question if you have a lifestyle where
you're not sleeping well where you're
not well hydrated if you eat too much
salt all of those things really affect
the area underneath our eyes because of
the bone formation surrounding our eyes
the skin is very thin and the way that
the light reflects from light that's
generally above us in this area can make
it seem darker than it actually is also
because the skin is thinner you can
generally see more blood vessels there
and blood vessels being veins and veins
are generally a bluish color how the
light reflects off that area can seem
darker or blacker than the rest of your
skin first and foremost what I would
recommend make sure you're getting
enough sleep make sure you're eating a
healthy diet not over eating salt and
you're staying well hydrated yeah you're
exercising because I say it all the time
exercise is basically a cure-all that
helps with almost every aspect of our
lives finally if you're still unhappy
with your appearance there are some
cosmetic things you could do there are
bleaching creams if it's a seriously a
color issue
there's also injections that you can put
right below the eye here which basically
act as a filler it basically lifts the
skin up off of the bone and it changes
the way the light reflects off of the
area and therefore the area seems more
full and less dark hey so I'm a
sophomore in high school and I'm super
interested in the medical field do you
have any recommendations for classes I
should take your videos are great I
don't think in high school you should
specialize your classes to get you ready
for med school and I'll explain why in
college you're already going to be
forced to take a specific set of courses
if you want to get into Medical School
and then once your medical school
obviously there's a curriculum so you
might as well spend your time in high
school to try and learn as many
different topic
very broad categories so you can figure
out if med schools for you or maybe
you're drawn to something completely
different like politics or something
even though right now the political
landscape is crazy but take a broad
diversity of classes see what you enjoy
see where your passions lie and I think
that's what's gonna make you a great
candidate for Medical School Tom do you
want to live in NYC your whole life or
move away in the future oh I don't know
why you haven't Oh in there I don't know
York City guy ever since I moved here
when I was six years old
I've lived in Brooklyn Staten Island
Long Island now in New York City I love
this place I call it home my family's
here Roxy's here bears here so I don't
know I think I'm staying here if not for
my whole life definitely for the
foreseeable future
good question Tom oh I love reading and
responding to your comments so please
continue filling up the comment section
as you know my answer them with in the
comment section I'm very active there
and I also do this monthly segment where
I read and respond to your comments
please subscribe to the channel because
it tells YouTube that you really enjoy
my content and that you want more of it
as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]